Well, if you've got a Bible, please turn to Acts chapter 17.
Here just a little bit I'll have Ethan come in and read it.
Just to share with you what we're doing at the moment.
We're starting a new series here called Firm Foundation, What We Believe and Why It Matters.
And last week we looked at the fact that Jesus is building his church.
And he's building his church on a rock on a firm foundation.
So what is that rock?
Well Ephesians chapter 2 and verse 20 speaks of Jesus as being the chief cornerstone, but
it also talks about God building his church on the apostles and prophets.
So Christ is the foundation of the church, but he's also, he's made known to us through
the teaching of the apostles and prophets, which we have here for us in the Word of God,
which centers on the person and work of Jesus.
So as Trinity Fellowship begins, you know, as this new church plant, we want to be built
together on the same foundation, on the firm foundation of the scriptures.
We want to be built in the foundation of Christ.
So throughout the fall, both on Sundays but also in home groups, we're going to be
working through our statement of faith as a church, just so we all know what it
says together.
And there are some foundational truths, I think it's nine foundational truths
that we find in our statement of faith.
And we'll come to a different portion of scripture each week where we see that
doctrine being taught.
And each week we're going to read part of our statement of faith, this part that
we're covering.
So if you would look on your worship guide, I'm just going to read it.
We're not going to read it together like we did earlier.
We see our statement of faith, what it says on God.
So you'll see that there at the bottom.
It says, we believe in one God, creator and sustainer of all things,
sovereign and supreme, existing eternally as three persons, father, son, and
Holy Spirit, with each person being fully God.
So why do we believe this about God?
Why does it matter?
Well, that's what we see in Acts chapter 17.
So Ethan, if you could come and read that for us, I would appreciate it.
Thank you.
Acts chapter 17 verse 16 through 34.
Now while Paul was waiting for them at Athens, his spirit was provoked within him
as he saw that the city was full of idols.
So he reasoned in the synagogue with the Jews and the devout persons and
in the marketplace every day with those who happened to be there.
Some of the Epicurean and Stoic philosophers also converse with him.
And some said, what does this babbler wish to say?
Others said, he seems to be a preacher of foreign divinities because he was preaching
Jesus and the resurrection.
And they took him and brought him to the Aeropagus saying, may we know that this new
teaching is that you are presenting or you bring some strange things to our ears.
We wish to know therefore what these things mean.
Now all the Athenians and the foreigners who live there would spend their time in
nothing except telling or hearing something new.
Verse 22.
So Paul standing in the midst of the Aeropagus said, men of Athens, I perceive that in every
way you are very religious.
For as I passed along and observed the objects of your worship, I found also an altar with
this inscription to the unknown God.
What therefore you worship as unknown this I proclaimed to you.
The God who made the world and everything in it being Lord of heaven and earth does not
live in temples made by man, nor is he served by human hands as though he needed anything,
since he himself gives to all mankind life and breath and everything.
And he made from one man every nation of mankind to live on all the face of the
earth, having determined allotted periods in the boundaries of their dwelling place,
that they should seek God and perhaps feel their way toward him and find him.
Yet he is actually not far from each one of us, for in him we live and move and have
our being, as even some of your own poets have said, for we are indeed his offspring.
Being then God's offspring, we ought not to think that the divine being is like gold
or silver or stone, an image formed by the art and imagination of man.
In times of ignorance God overlooked, but now he commands all people everywhere to
repent, because he has fixed a day on which he will judge the world in
righteousness by a man whom he has appointed, and of this he has given
assurance to all by raising him from the dead.
Now when they heard of the resurrection of the dead, some mocked, but others said,
we will hear you again about this.
So Paul went out from their midst, but some men joined him and believed,
among whom also were Dionysius, the Aropagite, and a woman named Demirus,
and others with them.
This is the word of the Lord.
Thanks be to God.
Let's pray together shall we.
The grass withers and the flower fades, but Lord your word stands forever.
So I pray that by your grace you would show us the truth of your word,
and we pray that you would take our lives and build them together upon it.
We ask all this in your name and for your glory.
Amen.
Well, the first time I ever traveled to the UK, I was with a couple of friends,
and we wanted to, we had 48 hours in London roughly, and so we wanted to
see as much of London as we could, so we kind of got on the back of,
or the top of one of these double-decker buses we can see out across,
and they take you to major sites.
We saw like Buckingham Palace.
We saw Big Bend, places like that, but also had another place I wanted to go to
that I heard about called Speakers Corner.
Has anybody heard of Speakers Corner before?
It's a fascinating place.
So it's in Central London.
It's in Hyde Park, and it's basically an area that people go to.
It's kind of an area where free speech is championed,
and people will go and give speeches or hold debates about all kinds of different things.
So you have, like, say, Muslim apologists who would be there kind of,
you know, talking about Islam, and then over here you'd have somebody talking about socialism,
and then over here you would have somebody talking about alien abduction,
and why their story is true, and you'd have all of these different people
sharing all these different beliefs about all these different things,
and as we walked up, it was on a Sunday, and we had just been to a church,
and we were walking up holding our Bibles, and we were just immediately,
like, sworn by people wanting to debate with us,
you know, thinking that we were there as Christians ready to debate,
and so we ended up, you know, these Orthodox Jews specifically came up
and wanted to have a debate with us about whether or not Jesus was the Messiah,
and they were ready for it.
But as I walked up, I remember seeing all of these different people going there
to hear about all these different new things or different ideas,
and thinking, this is just like Acts 17, what we read there,
because Paul has gone to the city of Athens, and Athens was the kind of intellectual
and cultural capital of ancient Greece.
It was a hub for philosophy, architecture, the arts.
It was also a place that was rampant with idolatry,
and people were sharing all of their different ideas,
but one of the things that you could see was the idols that people were worshiping.
One Roman author wrote that it was easier to find a God in Athens than a man.
It was home to many thousands of images, statues, shrines of all these different gods,
and many of them were formed by some of the greatest sculptors that have ever lived,
and some of these can still be seen in museums today.
But Paul, instead of being enamored by their beauty, was appalled by their blasphemy.
So as he saw all of these different idols everywhere, he was appalled.
His spirit was provoked within him, you see there in verse 16.
The word provoked can carry the idea of being irritated or stirred up even to the point of anger.
So Paul is stirred up, interestingly, the Greek translation of the Old Testament
that was being used at that time used the same word to speak about the jealousy,
the righteous jealousy of God when people worshiped idols.
So you read about that in Isaiah 65 or Hosea 8.
You see Yahweh alone is God, and he should be worshiped alone as God.
And since Paul knows the Lord and has a close walk with him,
it's no surprise that he is so disturbed as he sees all of these idols in the city of Athens.
So while he's stirred up about the idolatry, even angered,
it's clear that he has a heart for the people who are worshiping these idols.
He sees that they're enslaved by them.
He wants them to be set free.
And so he deals with the idolatry of the city, not with a sledgehammer kind of going to town.
He deals with it through speech.
He speaks to them.
He speaks up.
We read about how he first speaks to the Jews and the synagogue,
but then he then takes his message to the marketplace.
And when it says marketplace, we might think like a Walmart or a farmer's market or things like that.
But when it, the kind of marketplace it's talking about here is more of like a marketplace of ideas.
Right? So think Speaker's Corner or think maybe a, you know, a debate on a college campus,
things like that where there's this kind of public forum of ideas that are being shared and debated.
And Paul encounters all sorts when he enters this marketplace of ideas and begins speaking about God.
He encounters in verse 18 the Epicureans who to oversimplify were presuming a life of pleasure.
He encounters the Stoics who once again to oversimplify were presuming a life of self-discipline and meaning through that.
And then you just had your average Athenians who were there seeing what was happening and having discussions.
We read that they were there to tell or hear about something new as part of the culture in that area.
You know, the spirit of Athens is still alive and well today.
And it's available to stream on whatever podcast platform you use.
I mean, when you think about all the information that we have available to us today and all the ideas that get conveyed through that,
all of the idolatry and the gods and philosophies of Athens pales in comparison to all of the ideas that are floating around
and the next new thing that everybody's listening to and engaging with in the age of the Internet.
The fact is the people of Athens and the people of our day don't need to hear just some new thing.
They need a new life and that life is found in the true and living God who has made himself known to us in Jesus.
So this is what Paul preaches.
We're told that he preaches Jesus and the resurrection in verse 18 among these people.
That's what he comes preaching.
And he receives a mixed reaction.
But at least the door is still open for him to share more.
He's invited to what's called the Areopagus.
Now, the Areopagus was a literal place.
I mean, it's translated Mars Hill, like the God of Mars, the God of war in this hill is this outcrop of rock.
We had all of these idols there.
But you also had a council that was referred to as the Areopagus.
And they were the kind of gatekeepers that determined what gods would be allowed into the city.
Now, there are all these different gods, but you had to have this kind of council in place that was testing whether or not
you'd be allowed to preach this new God that you were bringing into town.
So when Paul comes preaching Jesus and the resurrection, he's then brought before this council to share before them.
And the sermon that he preaches, I mean, it is masterful.
It is both bold but also skillfully subversive.
And there's something to learn when it comes to proclaiming the gospel.
So he both connects with his audience as well as confronting them.
So he connects with them entering into their worldview.
He finds points of agreement and he says, like, for example, they have this altar to the unknown God.
And he said, well, this God that you're worshiping that's unknown, he's the one I'm going to declare to you.
So they're listening.
He quotes some of their poets instead of just kind of talking about the authority of Scripture from people who've never engaged with the Scripture before.
He engages with their authorities.
So he's connecting with them.
But then he's also confronting him.
He's showing the inconsistencies and inadequacies of their worldview and showing them that the life that they were made for,
that they're hungry for, can only be found in the true and living God.
And he contrasts the God that he speaks about, the God who's revealed himself to us in Scripture and in Jesus,
with the idolatry that they were involved in.
The world is still filled with idolatry today.
You know, we live in a pluralistic society that worships and serves all kinds of things that are not God.
Whether it be pleasure or power or possessions, we could go on.
And what these gods offer to us, so to speak, is nothing compared to the true and living God.
So how can we know the true God?
What is he like?
And how is he different to the gods of this world?
You see, God cannot be known through human philosophy or through art and imagination and idolatry.
Now there may be echoes of him found there within all of those things, like Paul pointing to the unknown God.
But those things cannot show us who he truly is.
And here we see that the unknown God is made known to us through the preaching of the Word.
The unknown God is made known through the preaching of the Word.
He is revealed when the message is proclaimed.
So Paul, like we said, he doesn't reference specific Bible passages here.
You can read about his sermons and synagogues.
He would be going from one Scripture to another, showing that Jesus is the Christ.
But in this audience, while he doesn't explicitly mention Scripture, everything that he says is Scriptural.
So God is revealing himself through the proclamation of his Word here.
So what is this God like?
Well, Paul doesn't say everything he could say here.
And what we have recorded for us is I don't think the totality of what Paul was saying here is summaries of what he was preaching in these places.
For example, you know, I saw our statement of faith that we read just a moment ago, speaks of God as Trinity, Father, Son, and Holy Spirit.
And certainly Paul is proclaiming the Father and he then ends with proclaiming the Son.
And when you look at it in light of the whole book of Acts, Acts chapter one and verse eight, sets the scene, says that he's proclaiming the Gospel by the power of the Spirit.
So the Trinity is present.
But that's not what he's kind of drawing out here.
So we don't have everything.
Here we see that God is greater than the so-called gods of the world.
And what I'm going to do, you can, when we say, like, OK, what does this passage teach us about God?
What does this sermon tell us about God?
There's about 10 things.
So I've managed to get it down to about seven.
OK.
And and we're in your thing.
Oh, no, how long are we going to be here?
The oven's on at home.
We're going to go just rapid fire and say, OK, what are what are these seven or more things that Paul tells us about God here?
OK.
And then how are we responding to this God?
So first of all, we see that God is Creator.
So Paul begins his sermon saying.
Verse 24, the God who made the world and everything in it being Lord of heaven and earth does not live in temples made by man.
So stop there.
So he begins with God as Creator.
He is the Creator of all things.
So I've got friends who've moved to a tribe in Papua New Guinea.
And this this tribe had never heard of the Christian scriptures, never heard of Jesus.
So they didn't just go straight into the gospel.
They had to go right back to there's a God and he is the Creator.
So this is where Paul begins here.
There's a Creator God.
He created all things.
And in this, we see that God exists above and outside of his creation.
So there is a distinction between the Creator and that which is created.
And those things which are created must never be worshiped and served as God as the Creator.
There must be a clear distinction there.
And by the way, you look at like 1 Corinthians 8.
If you entertain whether or not these gods are actually gods.
1 Corinthians 8, 4 says they're not God at all.
These are not gods at all.
They're so called gods.
And Paul points out, for example, how ludicrous it is to think that the God who created everything could somehow be contained in temples made, created by human hands.
This is a pretty bold move for Paul to make while he's literally standing like in this center of idol worship surrounded by all these temples.
He says God doesn't dwell in temples made by human hands, but they keep listening.
You see, God cannot be domesticated and brought down to a place where he can be managed by his creatures.
And that includes our own conception of God, like creating a God that makes sense to us.
He's not going to be contained in that.
Creation is not God, but it is a theater revealing the glory of God.
So whether or not you've ever cracked open a Bible and read Genesis 1.1, in the beginning, God created the heavens and the earth.
You are surrounded by the revelation of his existence and his power and his beauty in creation.
We can't escape it.
We might choose to ignore it, but we cannot escape it.
One Christian in a country where the church was being persecuted said, you can pull down our steeples, but you cannot pull down the stars.
Whereas God isn't just revealed in a church.
He's revealed in creation as well.
So he's creator, but he's also sustainer.
So let's read what it says next.
He says, nor is he served by human hands as though he needed anything, since he himself gives to all mankind life and breath and everything.
So God didn't just create everything in the beginning and then just kind of leave it to run its course.
Like I've got one of those little spinning tops in mind.
Like he kind of started it off and then just left it to go.
No, he sustains all things.
So Jesus said it this way in Matthew 5, he causes the sun to rise on the just and the unjust.
All right?
He gives rain as well.
Hebrews 1.3.
He upholds all things right now by the word of his power.
Colossians 1.17 talks about how in Jesus everything is held together.
So while God is distinct from his creation, he's actively involved in creation, sustaining it, keeping it going.
And that includes us.
He's the one who gives us life.
He's the one who gives us breath and everything that we need to live in the world.
When you breathe in, you're breathing in the oxygen that he has provided.
He's present and active right now.
And idolatry flips this around.
You got gods who are needy, created by us, needed to be sustained by us.
As I was thinking about this, I started thinking about that craze that took place in the 90s.
For those of you who are old enough to remember about gigapets and Tamagotchi's, did any of you ever get sucked into that?
I got pulled into that craze.
It was horrible.
They were these kind of, how would you describe it?
Like a little virtual pet that would be on a key chain and you had to keep it fed.
You had to keep it watered, make sure you had enough sleep and all the rest.
And it would just constantly make noise to kind of get your attention.
And I remember just getting fed up and just like slinging mine across the room.
It was just too needy for me.
All right.
God is not needy, right?
So Paul's surrounded by all these needy idols.
He said, God is not needy.
He is not dependent upon us for anything.
We are dependent upon Him for everything.
You could really make another point about God.
This is that He is self-existent.
He reveals Himself to Moses as the I am, whose existence is in no way contingent upon anything outside of Himself.
He is.
We are entirely dependent upon Him.
And He's so gracious.
There's another point for you.
He provides for His creatures.
And this should humble us and cause us to praise Him.
All right.
So He's Creator, Sustainer, but He's also ruler.
He's the ruler.
So if He created all things, then He's the ruler of all as well.
So Greeks believed in these separate gods who ruled over different domains of creation.
So you've got the God of the sky, Zeus, or the sea, Poseidon, or the underworld, Hades.
This could go on.
So when Paul asserts that God created the world and everything in it, in the context he's proclaiming that in,
he's asserting that there is one God who reigns over all.
And that includes not only the natural world, but also humanity and the nations of the world.
So go on to verse 26.
He says,
So God rules over humanity because He created humanity.
He speaks here both of the unity and diversity of humanity.
That is by design.
So the unity of humanity, spoken of here in the sense that God created us from this one
common ancestor, Adam.
So we all share this humanity as image bearers of God.
But also speaks of the diversity of humanity.
God created us with diversity in view.
He creates the different nations or ethnicities.
We'll look more at that in a couple of weeks when we look at humanity as the subject of the day.
We see that God not only rules over humanity though.
He rules over history.
So people's nations and borders have come and gone.
And God stands sovereign over them all.
He determines their allotted periods and the boundaries of their dwelling place.
You know, so Paul's been accused of bringing foreign deities into Athens.
But he's saying he's not a tribal deity.
He might be foreign in your thinking or in this place, but he is the God who is sovereign over
all nations in all times and all places, including our own.
He's guiding humanity with one purpose in view too.
What is that?
Verse 27.
That they should seek God and perhaps feel their way toward Him and find Him.
But then he says, notice this, yet He is actually not far from each one of us.
For in Him we live and move and have our being.
So that's the fourth thing we see about God here.
He is near.
He is the God who is near.
So God is the ruler who reigns over all things.
He's above all things, and yet He is the God who draws near.
So the philogians describe this as that kind of tension as God's transcendence and God's
eminence.
Those two things are both true about God at the same time.
So yes, He is outside and above all things, but He's also near and actively involved in our lives.
So you see this described, for example, in Isaiah 57, verse 15 in the Old Testament.
It says, Thus says the one who is high and lifted up, who inhabits eternity, whose name is holy.
I dwell in the high and holy place.
But then hear this, the God who dwells in the high and holy place.
He says, And I also dwell with him who is of a contrite and lowly spirit.
So His greatness and His nearness is there.
You know, people go to great lengths to find transcendence or a sense of meanings.
Back in the 60s or early 70s, you get the Beatles like traveling to India to find that there.
Kind of modern day example.
Might be that Tyler Childer is doing.
He's done the same thing.
Going on this pilgrimage.
People travel all across the globe to find God or whatever is ultimately found in him.
But the thing is, He isn't found by traveling off some distant place
or going up to some mountain somewhere.
He is the God who is near no matter where we are.
And He is known by those who will humble themselves before Him as He reveals Himself in the gospel.
Or says the God who's near.
He's also the God who is, fifthly, Father.
Father.
So what does it say here?
In Him we live and move and have our being.
As even some of your own poets have said, for we are indeed His offspring.
And Paul then affirms that.
The poets said that we are His offspring.
And Paul says being then God's offspring.
So he kind of affirms that.
So if you're listening closely, you'll think, well, hang on a second.
Are we all children of God?
Just to be clear, most scripture, when it speaks about being children of God,
it talks about how we are not naturally children of God.
You can go back to listen to the sermons from a couple of weeks ago.
We saw from John chapter three about what it means to be born again.
We have to be born again as children of God.
So why does Paul affirm what's being said here about us being children of God?
Well, he's not denying that we must personally become children of God through a new spiritual both.
Birth rather.
What he's doing is he's agreeing that there's a different sense in which God is the father of
all humanity.
So he's talking about God's fatherhood over all humanity.
In other words, God is the one who gives life to all.
So in that sense, he fathers humanity.
But also all of humanity is created in his image, in his likeness.
So in that sense, God is the father of all humanity.
But then we know him uniquely as father when we become his children through Jesus.
But thinking about his fatherhood in relation to humanity, and often when a baby is born,
people will say something like, oh, he looks just like his dad, or oh, she looks just like
her mother, or the other way around.
But what you don't hear is people generally saying like, when the father walks in the room
like, oh, you look just like the baby.
That might be true, but we think of it in the other direction.
So this is the flow of thought here.
So this is who God is, and we are created in his likeness.
And so it's then absurd to say that we can create a God in our likeness.
So it's the wrong way around.
So what does Paul say here?
He says, being in God's offspring, we ought not to think that the divine being
is like the father of all humanity.
The divine being is like created things like gold, or silver, or stone, or an image formed
by the art and imagination of man.
So we're the ones that have been created.
We do not create God, but sadly this is what people do.
And that can take place in the way that Paul is directly addressing here in his
context through created images of God that we worship.
But the same thing can happen in how we conceive of God in our minds.
So instead of submitting ourselves to the God who is, to the God who has revealed himself,
we conjure up the God we want to be, the God we want to exist.
We can create a God who is an image of how we tend to think or feel about things.
So that's what we want God to be like, because we want him to agree with us.
Or it can also happen to be a God who reflects whatever the cultural narrative that we are
buying into is at the moment.
So like wherever society is at, like well that's who God must be or what he must be like.
So sometimes you hear people say like, well I would never believe in a God like that.
That's not my God.
Well the question is not like who is your God, or what do you feel like God is like,
or how do you think about God, but who has God revealed himself to be?
We don't get the God we want, we get the God who is.
So many people are worshiping a, pardon me, but like a distorted Frankenstein like God,
who's created by taking all these different things that we think and feel, be it our desires,
or our politics, or our values.
We put all of that together with a bit of what Scripture says about God.
That is then what we worship.
You know there's a unique and grievous blasphemy that's taking place in our cultural context
that was not taking place in Athens.
And that is why we take that God that we create in our own image and we say that is the God of the Bible.
This is Jesus.
We're actually just projecting ourselves.
Worship belongs to the God who is and to him alone, not who we want him to be.
He will not be worshiped alone, side any other.
Sixthly, we'll just go through this briefly for the last two.
This God is also judge.
Verse 30 says, the times of ignorance God overlooked, but now he commands all people
everywhere to repent because he is fixed today on which he will judge the world
in righteousness by a man whom he has appointed.
And of this he is given assurance to all by raising him from the dead.
So remember Paul's audience here is judging whether or not he should be preaching this
so-called foreign God there.
But he lets them know they will not stand as judge over this God that he is proclaiming.
But rather this God will stand as judge over them and over all mankind.
And that includes us as well.
Hebrews chapter nine in verse 27 says it is appointed unto man once to die.
And after this the judgments there will come a day when we will all stand before God.
And he will judge with righteous judgment.
And he will judge with the man that he has appointed, this man who was raised from the dead,
the man Christ Jesus.
So he is judge.
But also you see in what Paul says here, this same God is Savior.
And that's what we'll end with here.
He doesn't say there's coming this day of judgment and your fate is sealed and there's
nothing you can do about it.
No, he says, no, yes there's coming a day of judgment, but this God who is judge is now,
right now calling everyone everywhere to repent.
He's calling upon us to turn away from our idolatry, these other creative things that we
are living for before it is too late.
And if God is calling us to turn from our idols to him, then that must mean that he is ready to
receive us.
So how do people respond?
Well Paul is probably about to say a bit more about this Jesus he's mentioning,
but then he's cut off by people laughing and mocking because he's spoken about the resurrection from the
dead.
But we know from the rest of his teaching and the rest of Scripture that yes, God stands ready to
receive us.
And he stands ready to receive us in Jesus.
Yes, Jesus will return to judge the world, but the first time he came we're told that he
did not come into the world to condemn the world, but that the world through him might be saved.
So what do we see in Jesus?
Well God is revealing himself.
This God who is creator, sustainer, and ruler takes on flesh.
We see his nearness in Jesus.
And then this Jesus who is the righteous judge takes our judgment upon himself and he dies in our place on the cross.
And then he rises again and God is proclaiming to us through this Jesus that he stands ready to receive us.
He says,
Turn to me all the ends of the earth and be safe for I am the Lord and there is none else.
Isaiah 45 verse 22.
But as we look at different responses here we need to ask ourselves how are we responding to him?
How are you responding to this God who's made himself known to us in Jesus?
We see that some in verse 32 mock and that continues on to this day.
And some say, we'll hear you again about this.
Some have interest and that's better.
But at the end of the day we're not called to just like entertain ideas about God and just
think about him ad nauseam, but rather we are to respond to God through repentance and faith.
And so we see verse 34 that some join and believe.
So a number of people in Athens turn from their sin and idolatry and put their trust in the living God.
Even one of the members of the council is named by name.
Imagine while his peers are there mocking him deciding to step forward and say,
well I believe in this Jesus that you are proclaiming and I want to be identified with him
and with his his people. So how do we come to God? The God who is we come by faith.
Hebrews 11 6 says he who comes to God must believe, must believe that he is and that he
is rewarder of those who diligently seek him. Then one final response.
Like as we believe in him we need to bear witness to his name.
You know once we come to know the Lord we need to be willing to be identified with him
even when it is unpopular, even when there is mocking because of that.
We have this wonderful example in Paul here.
He is not ashamed of this message and those who believe are willing to stick their necks out to
and join together as the Lord's people. So we are going to share in communion together and
communion is a wonderful opportunity to say together that we believe this message of the
gospel. When we respond in faith one of the ways that we respond we trust in Jesus and we
make that public in baptism and that baptism is a one-time event where we are making that public
that we believe the gospel. And then that then continues on in the life of the church through
communion when we are eating this bread together and drinking this wine because the bread reminds
of Jesus' body broken for us. The wine reminds us of his blood shed for us. So when we receive
that we are saying I believe in this Jesus who died and rose again. And my faith is in him.
We are experiencing his nearness together as we share in this meal together. So before we come to
the Lord's table I will give some instructions but let's take time to pray just personally where we
are and commit ourselves to the Lord and come to him by faith in our hearts before we come to
this table together. So let's pray.